[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
podcast in the [ __ ] list roundup
uh we we started [ __ ] list around the
break late because we had rachel
bittikoffer on the show
um it looks like we have someone joining
us now oh hey gabe uh you're probably
your fans your fans are gonna be happy
that you're here they were they missed
you yesterday they were sad you didn't
come yesterday so i figured
yeah i figured i would hop in for a few
say hello you know oh okay okay right
what's going on right right right as i
start the shitless round up here that's
good have you been on have you been on
twitter this morning yet and looking at
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
i've seen a few things obviously the
biggest news that just came out in the
last like
15 minutes was yeah what's going on over
there was uh supreme court some changes
happening going over there we got
retirement happening oh really yeah oh
well so i'm gonna have some [ __ ] to to
run down the list here then oh did you
not know about this i did not know about
this totally oh yeah you are breaking
news here on the tony michaels podcast
what what the hell look hey well let's
let's do this let's go over here real
quick to the uh the tweety tweets and
the trendy trend yeah it should be there
right at the top let's see let's go uh
stephen breyer
sounds like something's going on with
steven breyer what what's going on here
associated press says breaking justice
stephen breyer is retiring from the
supreme court the vacancy r created by
the liberal judge gives biden the first
high court pick of his presidency so um
it looks like um the news that you're
reporting is is that joe biden with a
democratic senate uh thanks to
republicans for carving out the
filibuster for supreme court justices
are going to be able to ram through any
[ __ ] justice that they want
[ __ ] men and i hope i hope they pick
the youngest most liberal [ __ ]
that they can find i don't give a [ __ ]
who it is i don't give a [ __ ] who it is
the most liberal young i mean that way
they can serve for like 60 years on that
son of what is the age requirement i
don't even know do you know
uh i don't know if there is an age like
a max or a man you mean
huh well i mean no no i do you have to
be a certain name you know you have to
be a certain age to run for president
run for right right right you gotta be a
certain age
requirement obviously specified
qualification for justice such as
education profession or native
native-born citizenship
oh so so a justice could essentially be
you know like in their 30s or something
maybe you should maybe you should uh
campaign to be the supreme court justice
well you know i would but it says the
justice does not have oh it does not
have to be a lawyer or a law school
graduate that's right they have no but i
have to be trained in the law
i don't know
well i mean you you've been on the
internet you've been on the internet i
mean yeah you know i mean
you're basically an expert right
i've been trained in uh internet law so
that's okay well
well yeah so so what what's your opinion
of uh uh obviously this is probably good
news for most democrats out there that
they're seeing that um justice stephen
breyer is because they do this to ruth
bader ginsburg they say oh she should
have retired years ago and obama so he
could pick um and obviously maybe maybe
that's affecting uh stephen breyer's
decision here
possibly i don't know if that's the case
or not but now you got some fans here hi
gabe they're they're all they're all
yeah
they're all uh yeah i don't know
here's a uh best case scenario we're
able to just follow what mitch mcconnell
did in the republicans in his
jam it through
sans
uh a coveted super spreader event
uh but if we you know worst case
scenario is
mitch mcconnell somehow finds a way to
push this out past the midterms and i'm
really hoping that doesn't happen
well so i i think i think that's a good
point and it's probably the worry on on
most people's minds but here's the great
part about if democrats grow a set of
nuts here and do what they should do
which is [ __ ] you you did it you did it
two weeks before the election right
right when right before it was oh we
can't do it because we're in the same
year
as an election
for obama and he was like
okay fine i mean also how we got
ourselves our current attorney general
um
because he was unable to become
supreme court justice because of people
like [ __ ]
uh mitch mcconnell and the rest of those
well yeah yeah
i mean i mean man they they you know
they bitched last week
about carving out the rule for voting
rights for all americans and the and
just after and this is not just mansion
and cinema every single republican got
up and harped on carving out the rules
to make sure that americans received the
right to vote
but
but they carved out the supreme court
rule so that way they could jam
amy coney barrett down our throat i mean
kathy griffin even says your supreme
court justice stephen breyer just
announced his retirement
can we please get a female woman of
color who is the same age as amy coney
barrett thanks
i totally agree i think i think i think
we should get i think they biden should
pick the pick that pisses them off the
[ __ ] most [ __ ] them i mean at this
point at this point it's it's worth
sending the political message that hey
we're not toying around with this
supreme court thing when we get picks
we're picking we're i saw someone i saw
someone online that said anita hill
should be the pick
uh which would
be very interesting that would be very
interesting that would be uh a
drama-filled bench
right right but you know
one of our favorite here who them says
mike lindell this is a quote
[Laughter]
president
president trump will appoint cindy
powell to replace stephen breyer by
valentine's day
i'm sure
i you know what's funny about this quote
hoodlum is
this is something that could be real
like this could you know like oh
absolutely like he's gonna be president
by september 89th and he'll he'll he'll
take power and i feel like mike lindell
picks up he picks a holiday on the
calendar and then says that is the day
in which this big event's gonna happen
and then you know it's like right he's
like the worst nose nostradamus indeed
right the worst edit
like most of them are like oh strong
dumb ass as well right it's trying to
trying to pick like dates that are far
out right right like they really try to
give it like three or four years at
least to really try to make sure to
stoke these people into this into this
frenzy but literally like before he can
blow up the balloon the balloons running
around the room in the far you know the
fart bloom right right it's like uh he'd
be like oh you know it's gonna happen on
february 29th and then completely
forgets that it's leap year you know
right right right right right right he's
like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ] guy thank
you hoodlum for your tweet hey hoodlums
always get the good ones doesn't it yeah
okay let's see what else we got here
coaster we got all the the news reports
here uh but we it looks it looks like
it's confirmed that he's retiring
um so who who do you think who do you
think could be i mean do you have
someone on your list you think oh i have
no idea you know who i would want you
know who i would want
who
i mean i'm just i'm just throwing out a
couple names here what are you gonna say
michelle obama no well i mean that could
be a name but i i i think i think her
husband barack obama would make a great
supreme court justice oh yeah um i think
i think i think that would be i mean can
you imagine kittens oh [ __ ] amazing
oh my god tucker carlson's panties would
set right on [ __ ] fire oh my god yeah
and i'm sure they feel like
there's this never happened before you
can't do this right and it's like yeah
sure i mean it probably won't happen but
at the same time there's no rule that
says it can happen right right like
there's no rule that says a president
can't be vice president you know
the one that probably isn't a great pick
um because you know
because uh she is older but the one that
would really i mean absolutely collapse
make them collapse is if hillary clinton
was the nominee i mean oh my god it
would just be like
oh you know what you know what joe you
know what joe biden should do here's
what i think he should do and maybe we
should campaign for this game maybe we
should put this out there in the twitter
sphere i think the person that would be
the absolute best nominee for supreme
court justice is hunter biden's laptop i
actually think that would probably be
the actual pick that we need is hunter
biden's life because you know democrats
love hunter biden's laptop like we're oh
yeah yeah absolutely obsessed with it i
would love to see hunter biden's laptop
on a zoom call you know right where it's
like hey listen i don't want to get
covered
i'm back at do you think do you think
hunter biden's laptop would be a dick
like gorsuch and not wear a mask to like
the proceedings uh
is he that is is hunter biden's laptop
that much of an [ __ ] i mean i don't
know i mean he's i feel like the the
laptop is like very ominous like right
we hear these things but it hasn't been
confirmed right so he's like there's
just like this
spectral beam that's out there
i love how we're pretending that 100
bucks laptop is an actual person no
there was there was a point in the back
of my head which is is is kind of crazy
because it would never happen
but right now you look at
um you look at how obviously republicans
hate
um
harris for obvious reasons right you
know she's a woman or she's a woman of
color
right see i need help uh
but at robinson robin says anita hill
here it would be kind of crazy if
uh
if somehow they were like all right cool
we're gonna
like
some shift happened and of course it
would be crazy like it would have to
happen mid term but if they're like
oh uh
harris becomes
uh scotus and
then there's a new vp that comes in
um
which
you know i don't know i that would be it
would be crazy i don't think it would
happen
but i could see both sides of the
argument where it's like oh she's
younger she's a woman of color
uh
so
so you're you're you're maybe maybe
putting your hat in the ring for some
sort of vice presidential
um
i don't know i think it comes up
i mean like i feel like she would
i feel like she would be a good
candidate potentially i don't know i
mean she's not obviously super like
progressive uh in that sense so like it
might you know she might toe the middle
of the line if anything
right but um you could have people on
both sides like oh this is great so we
can actually get someone who is more
progressive as a vp then some people
would be like republicans would say oh
great yeah um
clearly it's a failed administration so
you have to you know take her out but
it's like you know i don't know if
you're thinking long term
it's like what's the position you're
trying to put them in right like you
only you're only guaranteed another
three years of this administration right
how do you make an impact for more than
three years right well one one way is to
pick a supreme court justice that you're
not going to cow down to the whole oh
well they're bipartisan and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we we played that game we played that
game with these [ __ ] with merrick
garland um years ago and they absolutely
you know of course they were going to be
hypocrites about this thing but they
absolutely you know discounted all that
so why why should we go down that road
again so i think it would be a big
mistake if the administration even
considers someone who's a moderate or or
in that in that lane as such [ __ ] that
[ __ ] get the most liberal youngest uh
and i i think you're right a woman of
color and kathy's right too um because i
think i think that's the way that the
country goes because i actually think
that's what our leadership looks like in
the future now in the next generation is
women of color and it and that's what
really terrifies these [ __ ] tucker
carlson alpha cucks right like they're
[ __ ] completely terrified that women
of color will actually be governing them
because they feel like oh my god what if
what if they oppress us the way that we
want to oppress them that'll be horrible
right and you know the the secret is
that black people in this country you're
just lucky they don't want revenge they
actually just want equality and equity
right you don't want revenge the other
the other thing too is is how um
uh
like with any good team right you work
on or any good leadership team
especially you know in corporate america
like the best
uh the best
kind of
movements that are made or or growth
that is made within a company are done
by those that are a representation of
the people they serve right that they
represent and so if you've got
a person of color uh you know a
a person who's younger person who's
older a person who's white you know like
a wide range right you want an eclectic
mix of people who are smart and talented
but also come from a wide range of
experiences in in life uh you know and
upbringings and
uh geopolitical status and all these
different things because at the end of
the day
if you have the same white old man on a
bench or in a board room they're going
to make the same decision over and over
again and not learn from there as
opposed to having a diverse collection
of ideas and opinions and ways to
approach a case in this instance where
they would say actually
this would be
uh
so [ __ ] up right or this would be
great if it was done or whatever like
whatever their actual kind of
opinion or position is you get the best
ideas and the best outcome from a
diverse that's why i mean like when you
look at democrats it's like well why is
this group so much better than
republicans is because they're not
making the same mistake
whether intentionally or unintentionally
because they've got different people
coming in that's like uh no that doesn't
work anymore or you know what actually
based on my life based on my experience
or based on the constituents that
constituents that i represent
this is actually what needs to be said
well you know that that's a good point
because me and rachel um
earlier in the show we were talking
about democrats being this big tent and
everyone thinks that that's like a
downfall like no what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like that's the whole
point is to build a huge coalition now
is it challenging sometimes to get that
coalition behind one message and one
goal yeah but right now it should be
really [ __ ] easy like like we have no
better time than these clowns because
the way they're go their way they're
going to respond to justice steven
breyer stepping down they are going to
tonight on fox news they're going to be
burning down the house
they're they are going to be [ __ ]
terrified here because here's what amy
says and this is why they're going to be
terrified breaking supreme court justice
stephen breyer is retiring per nbc news
which will give
president biden a critical opportunity
to replace him with another
liberal justice
right so they're going to be absolutely
[ __ ] terrified terrified the good
news is is we're not into the election
cycle quite yet like we haven't been
through any primaries yet um so if biden
can make this pick and um which i'm sure
because this isn't like
um
a death of a justice where you know you
kind of have to step back and respect
you know um
and give give the justice that has died
their peace right no he's retiring he's
stepping down did someone give that
piece to exactly well i mean you think
you would if you were a [ __ ] decent
human being but they are not decent
human beings here i mean we're not
dealing we're not dealing with with
[ __ ] people who have souls
i mean if we look at uh
if we look at during obama's presidency
right like you had
i don't know somewhat less than a year
right before the election was done and
they're like well we can't make a big
decision like that
when
uh the presidency is up for you know the
the election
um
is up
uh uh uh that's upcoming right like we
can't make a big decision like that on
you know and we have to let the people
decide right so they hold off they push
it right and then it's
an election a big [ __ ] election 2020
and then we're like what a month out
we're you know october and they're like
okay yeah let's just like pump this bad
boy through and it's like whoa whoa
didn't you just say last the for the
last president that literally had this
happened to you guys said
no we can't do this and now you want to
do this well that's what they're going
to say again right and it's like
literally what they're going to say like
by this afternoon they're going to be
saying you can't do this during an
election year like they're going and
they're going to pound that drum because
they have
no [ __ ] bones about winning and
that's and that's honestly what the
democrats need to start doing they need
to start [ __ ] having no bones about
winning now we don't have to use
misinformation and lies and all the
[ __ ] we don't have to do that the
truth is on our side the majority of the
american people want what democrats you
know big d and small d democrats want i
mean they want pro-democracy they want
they want to get [ __ ] done on issues
like health care and education and wages
and and housing they want to do all
those [ __ ] things they want to do all
those things but the only party that is
willing to do it is the democratic party
they're the only ones that deliver
republicans want to destroy everything
and you will watch them
absolutely act like this country is
going to be destroyed
if joe biden replaces a liberal justice
with another liberal justice like
literally that's what we're talking
about we're not talking about a
conservative justice here that's being
replaced by liberal justice we're
talking about keeping the vote the exact
same right like there is there is no
the only
good thing about this is that we're not
gonna have the crypt keeper as the
supreme court justice right we can
actually pick someone who's young who's
vibrant who can go in who can fight and
make sure that they they
they at hold to the constitution and the
american people not this [ __ ] where
they're bought and paid for by some
[ __ ] special interest group and they
get they get their debt paid off to
become a supreme court justice still
wondering who paid off uh kavanaugh is
dead just saying right anyone if anyone
has the answer please come to us yeah
right democrat can do this democrats can
do this
um and they can do it well and they can
just ignore all the [ __ ] noise about
oh you're trying to destroy our country
like we're replacing a liberal justice
with a liberal justice right sit down
and shut the [ __ ] up but i can't wait to
hear that later today i mean like it's
probably already happening right now
where the people are you know fox news
and all of them are going to say you
can't do this and despite the fact that
when you said we couldn't do it then you
came back in a
in a much
a fraction of the time before
for an election and said because here's
the thing it wasn't even like when obama
was president it was like oh well he's
not up for re-election right like it was
it was uh uh it was four uh right wasn't
it two thousand
it happened before right when uh
who are you talking about
uh because
it was his second term where he tried to
put uh garland in right yeah yeah well
it was it was yeah it was the it was uh
it was the year before
2016. the cycle had not happened yet
right
right or was it 20 was it the end of
2015 or right right 2016 right right and
the cycle had not happened yet they had
almost over a year
um to seat a supreme court justice right
and the republicans wouldn't even
and because they controlled the senate
wouldn't even hold meetings with merrick
garland right
you know and and obama tried to pick
merrick garland in a way to
you know
basically have you know kowtow to the
the conservatives in that he's not
really he wasn't a conservative justice
he wasn't a liberal justice i mean
you know frankly merrick garland um i i
think he's more apolitical just because
of his career yeah that's been in front
of him um but
and maybe that'll show through as him as
attorney general for the department of
justice maybe we'll be very happy that
he wasn't um
named the supreme court justice not that
there couldn't be anyone else um do the
job of attorney general at this point so
i expect i wouldn't be surprised i'll
probably write some sketch about this
about just the basic it's just going to
be a conversation it's going to be so
[ __ ] dumb where it's like we want
supreme court no you can't have it right
why can't we have it because an election
year okay fine whatever well what about
the last order yeah oh we want a supreme
court wait you guys just said last year
that we couldn't have it right and then
it's like
you guys are you guys are witnessing
gabe right right the video right here in
front of you you guys said the president
no we didn't yes you did that's fake
news that it's literally what you guys
said right it's like you can already see
this conversation you already
and that's that's that's the point that
me and rachel were trying to make in the
last segment is that
on this issue alone like this issue
alone you don't have to [ __ ] guess
what they're gonna say
we shouldn't have to guess what we're
gonna say like literally like okay yeah
we're gonna replace a liberal justice
who's retiring with another liberal
justice who's younger that's that's the
thing that's what we're gonna do and
we're going to keep the vote the exact
same in the supreme court and i think
that's that's the you know to what you
just said is adding on to what amy said
here is like it's not just a
another liberal justice right because
then it's like okay whatever it's a
younger liberal justice because right
now right you know
there are no term limits for supreme
court uh supreme court justice there
there are uh no restrictions as to how
long they can serve unless something
happens right uh or or they uh retire or
resign
so i think that's the biggest
um
that's the biggest point right there
which is
a younger
a younger liberal justice because
they're going in i mean i don't know how
long it or how old is amy comey bear
like 30 some the late 30s early 40s i
you know i i don't know i i don't know
how old she is i know uh i know how old
she wants to be and she wants to be in
her [ __ ] 80s you know like jesus
christ jesus christ lady she is uh
due to do 49 okay so 40 years almost 50.
yeah i mean i i wouldn't be opposed to
having someone in their early 40s yeah
that's fine too but that's the thing i
think we're going to go live oh we want
to get someone in their lifetime which
is like you know you're looking at 49
you know
30 more years maybe of this person on
the on the bench potentially
so it's like you're trying to find
someone that's going to be able to
uh put a stamp on
uh on court decisions that you know rule
the land of america right like you want
to put them in a position that
that puts others uh in a in a
well uh
a strong
point right going forward you don't want
to have to like take away their rights
take away this and that like it's
something that's that's gonna be the
biggest thing which is
um
you want that's i think that's what's
gonna that's what's gonna upset them the
most is the fact that it's a younger
person that potentially a younger
liberal yeah i hope i hope it's i hope
but they're younger i hope they're a
woman um i think that's what needs to
happen i think i think there's gonna be
no one um in this country
especially if it's a woman of color um
that's going to help protect people's
rights um um not not just not not just
people of color but all people's rights
because that's that's where it needs to
swing down because i think they
understand the the ramifications when uh
not just a woman but also a woman of
color um
when they start to take away your
[ __ ] liberties how it affects a
person because um people of color and
women are the first ones they [ __ ]
start taking them away from uh the prime
example is texas and mississippi right
so you gotta have someone who has a
voice to represent that population right
right now you live out in l.a um i guess
today is the second anniversary of kobe
bryant's death in the horrific
helicopter crash
um it is trending because of that um are
they are they having big things out
there today or something i i don't i
haven't read down this thread possibly i
know that whole situation i'm like i was
on set that day when that happened and
everyone just like stopped and it was
like well you know what's going on and
they're like
it was a very it was a very strange
thing yeah it was like early afternoon
when it like dropped on twitter and i
was like what is going you know
everyone's like what the [ __ ] going on
and it was released that kobe bryant you
know was on this helicopter and then
like more details came out and it was
like holy [ __ ] like this is crazy and
obviously his wife you know is going
through a whole lawsuit right now
because photos were released
um
by the county sheriff i think it was
like they went out there took photos and
then that got leaked
you mean of the of the crash of the
crash site yeah so like don't respect
just like money grab kind of situation
right
and i think she's
i mean i i so is that still ongoing then
uh i feel like daddy but you know that's
the sh the shocking thing that day and
what it made i mean obviously it's kobe
bryant but it made it so strange is the
story of of uh him and his daughter
being in the helicopter and some other
parents and they were flying to i guess
basketball practice or something and of
course yeah the conspiracy theories
immediately start to spin
um almost [ __ ] immediately and you
know fingers start to get pointed
everywhere um
you know
especially when you have a person with
such a name like kobe bryant and his
family trying to trying to when him and
his daughter pass away in the helicopter
christ not just him yeah
so two things is the trial is nearing so
it's coming up i guess gotcha okay um so
i've got a buddy who is a helicopter
pilot um in in the navy
and this before covid we were able to
meet up and we were talking about um
this like what had happened right
because i was like i just like from from
a just know a person like i have a basic
understanding of what happened the fog
was dense it was you know difficult
whatever
and he was like so it's called uh which
you hear it in other other places too
it's called um is is it's called a swiss
cheese theory i think is what it's
called
uh or just swiss cheese uh but basically
it's like so like swiss cheese right
you've got holes and once you go through
one hole there's going to be another
hole somewhere else but that hole might
be smaller so you're trying to navigate
through small pockets right and that's
what happened in the fog
you know as a pilot you're making
you know split second decisions and so
you're like great i'm gonna navigate
through here but the fog was so dense
where they were traveling or where they
were flying and so it's like okay i'm
gonna
i'm gonna try and fly i'm making a
decision i'm gonna try and fly above it
but like i'm not able to break through
anything to see any sort of clearing
so you're making these decisions where
you keep going through and it's like
keeps getting more narrow and narrow and
narrow up until the point which like you
have no idea where you are then there's
also the sense of like because i can
only see white or like this gray i can't
see any sort of landmark or ground i
have no idea where i am outside of the
the regions that are there and some
people will lose a sense of themselves
uh at the right so they're just they're
kind of lost in the situation right
they're literally lost in the clouds
right and so that's what happened
whereas like you he was making decision
and it was one decision then another and
another system and like these were
uh making it more and more difficult to
get out of the situation because he
wasn't able to identify where he was
at that at that point right like and
then obviously it led to a crash
um unfortunately but that's you know
what they what when i was talking to him
he's like that's pretty much what
happened which is like they have you
know it's not uncommon
for pilots to find themselves in the
situation it's just like how you get
yourself out of it right
um so
yeah especially because like they left
out of the like i don't live too far
from the burbank airport and i believe
that's where they took off from which is
like 20 minutes from me
and
then they're you know then basically
what they're traveling is north
northwest of the airport and they're
just trying to make it through dense
clouds and it was just like
bad bad bad news of course merrick
garland is trending here as well i don't
know i don't mean dude
so so the kobe thing um
two year anniversary it sounds like his
wife is finally gonna see your day in
court over the pictures
but uh merrick garland is trending it
looks like for a couple different things
but obviously the supreme court some
people want
some people want joe biden to pick him
again i'm like oh my god people can
can we just stay one one [ __ ]
one list at a time this is you know this
is the [ __ ] that we do that gets us in
trouble i think michelle obama oh i
thought she was trending let me refresh
her she was i saw
yeah i seen that too um and i'm sure
it's because of the uh maybe she moved
up the list here no wait go down
there's uh
where was she michael rappaport
are you running the show on mine
uh man i thought it's not early
i feel like when there's any political
position that is like up for grabs
everyone's like michelle obama which is
like i think you know she'd be great in
the sense of like holding a position
of influence and power and doing what's
right for people you know
um it looks like people are it uh
how do you say her name
um i don't want to say it wrong but i'm
going to say it wrong there uh brown
jackson here uh
katanji i i don't know changi i think
that's it katanji um brown jackson
um i i don't know who this is they must
obviously they sit on the federal she
sits on the federal bench but some
people are suggesting her um i don't
know maybe that's a decent pick
um we got some here briar stepping down
here are your names
jackson uh krueger so jackson is in the
dc court yeah katanji brown jackson yep
uh how long has she been sir oh i don't
know how long she's been serving but
i i don't i don't know she uh um
ellie here has as that she's on the dc
court
um there's
uh leandra of cr kruger
which is on the california supreme court
which is uh in your neck of the woods
and then michelle childs which is on the
south carolina district court which um
the first um one would be uh federal
court the second one i believe is
federal court and the third one is not
exactly a federal court so um looks like
uh people are already naming
yeah some names out there now rather
biden actually
yeah i was gonna the other thing too is
like let's let's keep in mind that like
when you go into an administration
you've got you have already have lists
ready right like
you're like in the event that this
happens
this is who we want to go for right
and those might change based on events
that happen here and there right uh but
for the most part uh
they've got they've probably got a short
list ready to go you know well here's
here's uh joy reid um talking about this
um
can katanji uh i happen to know
so i think she's wonderful and she
actually made it to the
top three it was it was it was her
merrick garland and sri sriven nissan
they were the like top three choices for
the scotus and
president obama chose garland so so
they're that that's what joy is
reporting so i don't i don't know if um
you know i i'd have to verify that but
i'm sure joy is on top of that that she
would be on the high list when obama was
picking merrick garland
when the republicans wouldn't even give
him um the time of day to even give him
a meeting do you think
do you think uh
just for shits and giggles biden will
put ted cruz on unless justifiable
i don't know i think that would be
pretty funny maybe that's a good video
is a ted cruz waiting waiting to see if
he's on by like he was on the list for
trump right he didn't make it obviously
because he's like oh i don't want that
job but i look at it i'm like you know
does biden come in and say oh well you
know for the
the good like i want to show you guys
that i can i can do well for you you
know like does he put ted cruz on the
list and then he just like [ __ ] him
right and he's like uh i'm just [ __ ]
that wasn't really serious
it looks like it looks like brown here
um
someone's giving us some information um
confirmed 53 to 44 in 2021
she was a former dc district um but uh
she's 51 years old so i i don't have
that confirmed but someone's saying
she's about 51 years old which is about
the exact same age as amy
yeah yeah
joey has to say here
so there are a lot of people are
disappointed i will say i was one of
them um and then all of this drama
played out with merrick garland being
just completely sort of humiliated by
mitch mcconnell and just not they
wouldn't even meet with him wouldn't
talk with him well now look at karma
he's now attorney general and that opens
the door for katangi brown uh
she is the person most thought of as
being next up for us go to c tell us
about it um so so this is this has
obviously been a while back and i think
i think um newsbuster's put this
from march 30th so let's see
yeah so i think look any of those three
would have been a great jurist and
katanji would be a great supreme court
justice she is brilliant she's got a
deep soul she's a great writer she's
collegial all the things that
republicans hate
oh she's she she's thoughtful she's a
decent human being like she sees others
empathy
for the human condition she's read the
constitution right
you know all the things are like [ __ ]
this is ridiculous those are all the
things we don't want she would wear a
mask in court right she wouldn't crazy
she wouldn't be an [ __ ] and respect
other people's [ __ ] wishes uh for a
simple [ __ ] mass to keep someone sick
she's not a bomb thrower she's gonna fit
in incredibly well on this new court the
dc circuit our nation's second highest
court i also think there are other
people too in that league and so i don't
think we should write them off like you
know leonard krueger who's a justice on
the california supreme court who's about
the best lawyer i've ever worked with um
and you know so there's other people too
but you know i think what the president
did here is say here's a great person
for our nation's second highest court
she should go up today and along with
this other just rich diverse
competent slate of nominees i mean this
is just a really incredible day so she's
been in office or she's been she's been
a uh uh a judge almost a year in that
position right
uh i believe so yeah okay
yeah so
in the dc circuit right right so she's
been a federal judge in the dc circuit
for a little under a year
right yeah
i mean i mean she's smart and she knows
what she's doing and why not like you
know anyone should be given an
opportunity i mean look at the [ __ ]
people we have on the on the [ __ ]
bench right now yeah right well you know
the the the three that were bought and
paid for are right yeah we got one guy
who likes beer another guy who you know
he cries in his beak cries right right
he cries in his beard we got another guy
who uh let the company what was the the
case with the driver who died in the
snowstorm right in the truck and then
that was gorsuch and uh he you know uh
sighted on the on uh for the company as
opposed to the
the victim which is the driver and then
you've got you know the um
uh
under his eye
you know
[ __ ]
federalist
uh i want well i mean this nate's tale
it's pretty easy they're [ __ ] bags right
right yeah yeah i mean i mean like you
said not one ounce of empathy you know
not one ounce of of
american patriotism inside of any one of
them it's all about it's all about who
they who who bought and paid for him in
the first place
um breaking uh mueller she wrote says
justice breyer to retire hoping potus
nominates the first black woman to
scotus katangi brown jackson to replace
him so this is uh this is a movement
that's starting to happen i would
imagine that she's going to start
trending here on on twitter soon so get
your tweets
get your tweets written if you want to
be in the trendy trends and the tweety
tweets because i think um if you have
something to say about miss brown
jackson you're you're gonna you're gonna
trend here because she's gonna looks
like she's gonna come out to the
forefront because like joy said she was
the second on the list for barack obama
when he picked when he picked merrick
garland so right um
very interesting uh let's go back to the
there's something else i think there was
something else i wanted oh yes oh yes
the kid rock thing um i want to get your
take on this do you see